chez les éléphants qui qui promènent les
personnes âgées si on peut dire entre
deux qui sont plus solides qui
surveillent le petit enfin nous
maintenant on les met à l'hôpital et
puis ça y est on s'en débarrasse c'est
plus pareil la famille n'est plus comme
elle était autrefois elle d'abord il y a
trop de moyenne de
transport il y a des facilités enfin
quand vous pensez que des jeunes gens de
15 ans ont déjà fait le tour du monde
alors que à mon époque des gens de cinq
années qui sont à 13 km d'Aix n'avait
jamais vu Aix
je crois que le progrès a dépassé
l'homme n'a pas pu suivre je crois qu'il
est en retard et par conséquent il lui
faudra c'est difficile avec toute la
politique qui se met au milieu la
famille qui n'est plus la famille il y a
quelque chose qui doit changer c'est pas
possible que ça continue